Speaker 1: Let's speak to some of these great
people, members and nonmembers alike.
We take calls on Fridays via Discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go next to Alex from Baltimore, Alex.
Go ahead.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
It's cool.
I got a question about it.
I got a question about a publicly funded elections.
Sure.
So.
I know it's a long shot in the United States,
but so hypothetically, if one were to happen.
How does the money get doled out because I
know, you know, if it's a governor or president,
technically there's like eight independents
and a bunch of other random parties no one's
heard of.
So do they get a share of the money or is
it do they have to meet a certain qualification?
Speaker 1: This is a great question.
This is a great question.
So listen, there's no one way to set this
up, but you could you could establish.
So what do we mean by public funding of elections?
The idea is to limit the amount of money that
can go into an election, and it and I have
to say it's so loud where you are.
Alex, would it be OK if maybe I mute you to
answer, because this is a very important issue?
Speaker 2: Hang on, can you hear me better
right now?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I can hear you fine.
It's just there's so much background noise,
so the way we would set it up would be.
We might say, OK, once you meet a certain
signature threshold, then you qualify and
it can't be like 300 signatures, right?
It really has to be significant.
So you don't have 100 people.
Then you get X amount of money, you get x
amount of local television time and whatever.
You could do it on a polling basis, you have
to be polling at least X percent.
Now some people will say, Well, the problem
is you need money to get the polling and it
OK.
But so that's that's another way that it could
be looked at.
You also might have different thresholds,
depending on the population of the state or
the race that you're you're running.
So you wouldn't necessarily expect, you know,
a Senate candidate and a congressional candidate
to have the same thresholds in terms of signatures,
at least because one is drawing from a much
larger population base.
So there's not one answer to the question.
But it's a really important question that
has to be crystal clear when you put these
systems in place.
Speaker 2: OK, cool.
Yeah, I figured that was the end.
I also didn't know, is there any examples
of other places that do it?
Speaker 1: I don't have any offhand, to be
perfectly frank.
Speaker 2: Hmm, interesting.
Yeah.
Let me
Speaker 1: research that.
Speaker 2: Let me ask you one more quick.
I promise.
Sure.
What is your guilty pleasure foods?
The thing that's just greasy and nasty and
no nutritional value, but it's delicious and
you tear it up every time.
Speaker 1: Man, I don't know greasy and nasty.
I avoid foods I consider nasty, you know?
Speaker 4: Well, I mean, like looking tasty.
Speaker 1: I don't.
I don't know.
I mean, like,
Speaker 2: you know, a cheese steak that's
all spread out.
You know, it looks a certain way.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
No, I'm not big.
I mean, I think you know, the the Argentineans
slash Italian chicken dish Milanese, which
is a fried chicken cutlet I am a big fan of.
I guess that would be considered greasy, although
I don't have it very often.
Speaker 2: I guess I could also say, what
about like a dessert, like something that's
overly ridiculously sweet?
And I'm a big
Speaker 1: I'm a big tiramisu guy.
Speaker 2: A yeah, that's not a bad choice.
Yeah.
All right.
That's all I had.
Thanks for taking my call.
Alex, quick
Speaker 1: question Would you agree that the
top desserts are tiramisu full-on chocolate,
lava cake and pistachio baklava?
Do you agree with that?
Speaker 2: Take in?
You have a very Mediterranean cake on desserts,
don't you?
I'm I'm kind of a good old American boy when
it comes to desserts.
Oh, please
Speaker 1: don't bring up apple pie.
If you bring up apple pie, we're going to
have to cut it off.
Speaker 2: Let me meet you in the middle.
Then how about a key lime pie
Speaker 1: that's less obvious?
Overtly offensive?
Speaker 2: I'm more of a tart sweet guy, so
it's things like apple pie, lemon meringue,
that kind of stuff.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, we'll agree to disagree.
My friend, thank you.
Speaker 2: Yes, very respectively.
Of course,
Speaker 1: people can have differences of
opinion and still communicate in a respectful
way.